[موسيقى]
السابع عشر من مارس 2003 جورج بوش يمهل
صدام حسين 48 ساعه لمغادره العراق
التاسع عشر من مارس 2003 جورج بوش يعلن
الحرب على العراق
العشرون من مارس 2003 بدء الغزو الامريكي
للعراق
التاسع من ابريل 2003 دخول القوات
الامريكيه بغداد واسقاط تمثال صدام الاول
مما يو 2003 جورج بوش يعلن انتصار امريكا
في العراق
الثالث عشر من ديسمبر 2003 اعتقال صدام
حسين
السابع عشر من يناير 2004 تقرير يقول
المعلومات عن اسلحه الدمار الشامل جميعها
تقريبا مغلوطه
من نوفمبر 2004 هجوم امريكي على الفلوجه
بمشاركه نحو عشره الاف جندي
الثاني عشر من يناير 2005 البيت الابيض
يعلن عن انتهاء عمليات التفتيش دون العثور
على اسلحه الدمار الشامل
الثلاثون من ديسمبر 2006 اعدام صدام حسين
الشنقن
الحادي والثلاثين من اغسطس 2010
اوباما يعلن نهايه المهام القتاليه
الامريكيه في العراق
السادس من يوليو 2016
تقرير لجنه تشيل كود حول حرب العراق يقول
المزاعم الاستخباراتيه حول تطوير العراق
لاسلحه الدمار الشامل كانت معيبه